oubliez pièces et autres billets
aujourd'hui on parle de bitcoin cela
fait quatre ans que vous entendez
sûrement parler de cette crypte monnaie
elle affole de nombreuses personnes
espérant remporter le jackpot
y compris chez nos lecteurs au delà du
risque individuel le bitcoin peut-il
être dangereux peut-il dérégler le
système financier en temps de voir plus
clair dans facture d'abord petite piqûre
de rappel
c'est quoi le bitcoin c'est une monnaie
virtuelle décentralisée c'est à dire pas
de cash et par banque
à la place une block che une base de
données où est stocké l'historique des
transactions pour que votre paiement
soit validé puis inscrit dans cette
doctrine des participants appelés des
mineurs vérifient l'authenticité de
l'opération en attendant d'arriver
peut-être un jour à payer votre
boulanger en bitcoin vous pouvez tout de
même faire des achats sur le site de
north vpn pacte peu de commerces accepte
les victimes et pour contrer cela des
services se développent pour pays en
crypto gones n importe où quelque part
est ce que la nécessité d'accepter le
bitcoin aujourd'hui est une question
problématique s'est pas dit parce que la
technologie risque d'évoluer par exemple
au niveau bas de ces cartes bancaires là
dans le sens où on aura peut-être même
pas besoin de faire en sorte de créer
des services de paiement ou du moins des
systèmes de paiement et de colle on
pourra peut-être juste passer sa carte
bleue comme et qu'elle soit en dollars
en europe et indonésienne en bitcoin des
termes de volumes de transactions
traitées
ça reste quand même très très marginale
donc absolument rien de comparable par
rapport à ce qui est traité sur le
dollar et est ce que un système comme 10
à pau accent mais en termes de s'il ne
circule pas beaucoup c'est parce que
deux groupes se distinguent au sein de
la communauté bitcoin d'un côté ceux qui
le voient comme une véritable monnaie et
de l'autre ceux qui le considère plus
comme un investissement qui a d'ailleurs
bien profiter de la crise ducobu en un
an la valeur du bitcoin est passé
d'environ 7000 à 55 milles dollars
des entreprises se sont mises à investir
dans la crypte aux monnaies le 8 février
elon musk a annoncé que son entreprise
tesla acheter des bitcoins pour 1,5
milliard de dollars
pour autant le bitcoin est un
investissement très volatile son cours
peut partir à la hausse ou à la baisse
très rapidement très clairement
lorsqu'on investit dans la crypte
monnaie on investit surtout dans la
vitrines en fête dans le la technologie
qu'il ya derrière le docteur est en fait
à la manière du prix d'une action le
prix du bitcoin c'est sa vitrine et
démontre la valeur fondamentale de les
investisseurs sont à la recherche de
placements très rentable mais en finance
la rentabilité va de pair avec le risque
donc si on veut de la rentabilité
forcément il faut accepter des
placements risqués
or le bitcoin est décrit comme sonné son
déplacement sont associés à un cours
très volatil après les particuliers et
les entreprises
ce sont des banques qui s'intéresse
désormais à investir dans ce secteur
comme jp morgan qui en 2010 est qualifié
la crypte monnaie d'escroquerie
aujourd'hui elle annonce vouloir
s'impliquer dans le bitcoin mais dans
quel but
de plus en plus voit le bitcoin comme
une valeur refuge
capable de concurrencer lors cette
crypte aux monnaies est d'ailleurs
limité à 21 millions d'unités
afin de préserver sa valeur c'est
considéré actuellement
effectivement comme une réserve de
valeur presque aussi bonne que l'or sauf
que ces volatiles attention face à sa
popularité grandissante labenc of
america s'est montré très critique
envers la crypto monnaie le beacon
serait pour elle la mère de toutes les
bulles si les banques paris de plus en
plus sur cet investissement faut-il
craindre pour la stabilité financière
il vient tout dépend du moment où cela
se produirait si elle éclate aujourd'hui
cette bulle là
elle va avoir dès qu'on ait des
conséquences sur marchés financiers
quelques investisseurs vont perdre leur
argent
d'autres vont le gagner et ça va
s'arrêter là pour l'instant je ne
m'inquiète pas pour la stabilité
monétaire
je le dis bien pour l'instant si
l'ensemble des acteurs financiers sont
exposés aux mêmes types d'actifs en même
temps et qui a une très forte correction
lagarde risque d'instabilité financière
de type crise financière qui pourrait
déstabiliser les systèmes financiers et
encore une fois qu'est une réponse des
banques centrales
une réponse des institutions publiques
pour assurer un sauvetage des du système
bancaire pour l'heure l'union européenne
souhaite réguler le milieu des crypto
monnaie et leur créer un statut propre
d'ici 2023 chose qui pourrait rassurer
les investisseurs qui souhaitent se
lancer dans ce secteur
[Musique]
e